en el vídeo anterior terminamos
preguntándonos cual está cantidad de
jugo deberíamos producir si el precio
del mercado si el precio del mercado es
de 45 centavos como vimos en el vídeo
anterior nosotros queremos producir lo
más posible para poder distribuir
nuestros costos fijos pero no queremos
producir tanto como para que nuestro
costo marginal sea mayor que nuestro
ingreso marginal cada unidad incremental
que obtendremos la venderemos a 45
centavos por lo que queremos encontrar
la cantidad en donde nuestro ingreso
marginal de 45 centavos es igual a
nuestro costo marginal y esto está más o
menos por acá
45 centavos hasta para acá y este es
nuestro costo marginal
está aquí
podemos verlo en esta tabla
es que nuestro costo marginal es de 45
centavos esto lo logramos cuando
producimos 8 mil galones de jugos aquí
marcamos cuando producimos 8 mil galones
de jugo ahora la razón de que esto sea
interesante es que en ese punto la
cantidad de ingresos que obtenemos por
unidad nuestro ingreso marginal es menor
que nuestro costo total por unidad aquí
está nuestro costo total vendemos cada
unidad a 45 centavos pero nuestro costo
total promedio fue de 48 centavos por
unidad así que esto de aquí en nuestro
costo total y ustedes podrían decir oye
mira estamos perdiendo en cada unidad la
cantidad total de ingresos que estoy
obteniendo es menor a los costos que yo
estoy invirtiendo en generar estos jugos
este rectángulo es la cantidad de
unidades por el ingreso total que aquí
estoy sembrando con cuidado esa es la
cantidad de ingresos que estoy
obteniendo mientras que mis costos están
en este rectángulo más grande mi
cantidad por mi costo total por unidad
así que con lo que terminó es si tomamos
estos ingresos y se los restamos a la
cantidad del costo vamos a terminar con
una pérdida de exactamente esa sección
que estoy sobrando aquí vamos a estar
operando justamente en esa situación en
pérdidas operamos con pérdidas si el
producir ocho mil unidades nos cuesta 48
centavos por unidad y las tenemos que
vender en 45 centavos tiene sentido
hacer esto siquiera veremos cuál es la
pérdida estamos produciendo 8 mil
unidades las vamos a vender a 45
centavos cada una y nos costó 48
centavos por unidades producirlas
nuestra pérdida va a ser de punto 3
centavos por unidad por galón ahora esto
lo vamos a multiplicar por 8 mil galones
y nos va a quedar que vamos a perder 240
dólares 8 mil por tres centavos nos da
24 mil centavos o lo que es lo mismo 240
dólares así que esto no tiene sentido
que lo hagamos
a hora de pensar en esto es imaginar que
no lo hacemos decimos oye no voy a
producir ningún galón entonces cuál
sería nuestra pérdida si es unimos que
este es nuestro costo fijo con el cual
ya nos comprometimos de tener este gasto
durante al menos un año si no producimos
ni una gota de jugo de naranja aún así
vamos a tener que estar gastando esta
cantidad de gastos fijos así que si
acabamos produciendo nada nos estamos
garantizando una pérdida semanal de mil
dólares así que esta pérdida es mejor
que esta otra pérdida así que al
comenzar a producir algunas unidades
seremos capaces de poder equilibrar
algunas de estas pérdidas si
distribuimos nuestro costo fijo entre
más y más galones y ustedes pueden decir
oye por qué no seguimos produciendo más
y más unidades porque no llegó hasta
aquí in cruzando las nueve mil unidades
donde el costo marginal es más alto que
nuestro ingreso marginal y la razón por
la que no tiene sentido hacer esto es
que si producimos todas estas unidades
de pronto cada una de estas unidades
incrementales que se producen más allá
de los 8.000 vamos a perder dinero en
ellas a partir de las 8.000 unidades
marginal va a ser mayor que el ingreso
marginal por lo que estaremos perdiendo
más dinero van a comenzar a tener una
ganancia mucho menor que esta pérdida de
240 dólares quizás las pérdidas van
aumentando a 400 dólares o 500 dólares y
así sucesivamente va a aumentar esta
pérdida así que no es buena idea
producir más de 8 mil galones y
hablaremos más a detalle al respecto en
vídeos futuros pero esto es en esencia
en lo que diferencia la curva de
materias primas a corto plazo con
respecto a la curva a largo plazo de las
materias primas en el corto plazo voy a
asumir estos costos fijos por lo que
tiene sentido producir algo que es igual
a nuestro costo marginal pero a la larga
quizás nuestras máquinas nuestro capital
se desgasta quizás nuestro contrato con
los empleados cambia de términos y
después tengamos una estructura de
costos fijos completamente diferente eso
lo veremos en un vídeo futuro pero la
respuesta sencilla es que asumiendo que
estos son sus costos fijos reales
ahora si se deben producir tantas
unidades como sea posible para que
nuestro costo marginal sea igual a
nuestro ingreso marginal que en este
caso es el precio del mercado por lo que
de hecho es racional producir 8 mil
unidades asumir la pérdida de ello la
pérdida de 240 dólares a la semana en
lugar de producir nada y tener una
pérdida garantizada de 1000 dólares a la
semana lo que no es racional es que una
vez que estas cosas se agoten que la
máquina se desgaste que se cambie el
contrato con los empleados en ese
momento ya no sería racional continuar
con esta producción una vez que ha
sucedido todo esto pero pensaremos en
ello en otro vídeo ya que obviamente
estamos trabajando con pérdidas no va a
ser un buen negocio para estar pero ya
que entramos al negocio pues podríamos
tratar de mantenernos en el para tratar
de recuperar algunos de nuestros costos
aquí o al menos distribuirlos o al menos
no tener una pérdida de mil dólares a la
semana nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo